hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to papers please all
right so
we got this double click inspect i'm
hoping that it just means i can click on
a piece of information that doesn't seem
right and it'll automatically do it
that would probably be much too easy but
either way let's do this come on i'm
ready for you
i need to make some money because
otherwise my family is going to starve
hey what's up bud
how you doing you ain't bald dude what
is this
okay maybe you are bald never mind okay
so it's not that way the space bar is
just as easy why would they
why would i do that it's it's no any
it's not any easier
jack off all right i guess this works
oddly enough it works have a good day
[Music]
should we evacuate for that little oh
god oh god
[Music]
what do you mean horse bomb a simple
microwave let's just cut the wires in
order
okay one two
three four okay all done back door
oh my god
okay good great this is great this is
good dark hair
this is what you would call dark hair
okay match is cool yeah okay let's you
know you're
you know you're good you're good just go
ahead have a good day
great i don't know if they're i don't
know if they're allowed to have like
multiple things happen to him
plan to work okay sure you do sure you
do
work you know what if if i gave him a
thing
it must be okay that's what i'm guessing
if i was able to give him a card it must
be all good
and i was right oh my god
dude dude
well you're not getting in that's the
thing good
oh hi pal give me the coded documents
sure there you go whatever dude give me
something in return
both agents ourselves was born the order
fulfilled the same world state when
tyranny ends we will disappear again
sure okay thanks pal do i get paid for
this
kalechia huh matches
okay that matches transit would you say
a couple of days
nope nope this is expired
that's not a good excuse have a good day
offer me bribes maybe then i'll talk
alton that's good 181 that's
a little ambitious your weight's a bit
different
what's this on your leg i don't even
know what that's supposed to be
sorry pal you gotta go you gotta go you
gotta go bro you gotta go
you gots to go canistora
yep sixty uh what do you guys going on
here
what's all that for come on you're
killing my average my dudes you're
killing my average
oh my god how many times do we gotta
tell you no weapons
no weapons oh these people they
constantly just like
oh yeah whatever i'll bring grenades on
my back
not gonna happen my dudes not gonna
happen
hey what's up is this you yeah
okay 175 that's pretty good 56.
we got burnt in that's good paradisma
nope we got a problem here sorry you're
uh
expired nah this is a typographical
error
have a good day later nerd
all right the ministry of income has
cleared all wrongdoing your savings will
not be returned a cheaper class a
department is available
well why won't they be returned if i'm
cleared of all wrongdoing then shouldn't
i be returned
shouldn't all of it be returned to me
shouldn't it all be returned
apparently it should not all be returned
but whatever hopefully i get some bribes
tomorrow
ministries fight over staff qualified
guard soldiers in demand consolidation
resignment at border
okay what does that mean for me fight
overstaff does that mean i'm gonna get
paid more
what's the deal what's the deal my dudes
key the ministry of justice is pretty
appropriated the outer guard detail you
are now responsible for controlling
trespasser activity the provided key can
be used to unlock the tranquilizer gun
once an alarm has been raised
i'm sorry what compensation you will
receive a bonus for stopping any
trespasser or smaller bonuses provided
for firing on but missing your target
weapons protocol review instruction
diagram on the following page
when the alarm sounds drop the key on
the tumbler to unlock a weapon select
the gumma inman fire time is short act
fast
i'm sorry oh i am sorry
where is where where where am i
where all right whatever let's do this
yeah that seems right
hey bud can i get my bonus you die
did
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right thanks thank you i guess thank
you i guess
i'm in charge now i suppose
hi how are you uh kolechia huh
that's interesting okay height this is
all good dark hair i guess that makes
sense
numbers good okay i wanted to find
something bad about this but apparently
it's good
cause no trouble okay
you need like
[Music]
only our associates you know what hey
this is good stuff
i appreciate it i love a good bribe i
love a good bribe
i love a good bribe i love a good bribe
i love a good bride
you are back how many engineers did you
meet i got four calls
three were civil engineers useless i
need mechanicals i told you
what do you mean mechanicals it didn't
say oh
well thanks oh my god thank you
all right have a good one hey take care
of you jesus christ i'm piling on the
money
today is a money day hey what's up how
you doing
you passed through two days
pauline okay that's good overweight
according to who
170s a little ambitious
outer grooves outer grooves yeah outer
grooves oh what's this
all about look i don't judge but they
make me ask
all right well they make me ask look
it's not me it's not on me
well interesting
there's a bit of a problem sorry friend
sorry i don't make the rules in fact i
don't even enforce them half the time
hi one month date's good
that's whoa oh god oh wait wait wait
wait
okay okay grab the gun
oh got you what do you think you're
doing to me you ain't doing nothing
[ __ ] you ain't doing nothing i got you
[Laughter]
yeah goddamn wow
wow i didn't get very lost salary but
hell the bribes out my ass
so many bribes i got a feeling that all
this is going to come to a head it's
soon
graston incident highlight security risk
further breach is predicted
and tegri and whistleblower turned away
from united fed
let me guess i got to do more who the
hell are you
who the hell are you green man okay
[Music]
hi hello
[Music]
heard that you were from nurse
i grew up there but i have not been back
in many years
still as shittle as before of course
this is what i remember too
i am sergio it's good to meet you i will
do my best to keep you safe
okay thank you that's nice you're nice
you're probably gonna die
i have a funny feeling that you're gonna
die but i'm gonna keep you safe my
friend i'm gonna keep you
safe ain't nobody gonna get through with
any kind of explosive device ain't
nobody gonna do nothing to nobody what
is this
diplomatic discussion you say well uh
the seal looks good the name is
not good there's a discrepancy here
well let's double check just in case
okay this matches all right kim
robadinska
okay all right looks good
better uh update that info oh hey
welcome back
[Music]
border attacks are not easy unknown
extremist groups are responsible the
order aims so we can corrupt power sun
will not injury innocence is
we'll arrive today and uncover
extremists okay
but who today
oh interesting i don't know what this is
all about but
okay okay yp9 interesting
oh interesting is that important is this
what it needs to be
dude i don't know
i don't know well something's happening
there whatever
oh it'll probably say easy it'll
probably say easy right okay either way
you're good you're good to go
it'll probably say easy that's what
it'll do it's going to say ezik on it
press eh
let's see something here
[Music]
nope this ain't nothing to nobody it
ain't nothing
nobody sorry you can't get in
you don't have the paperwork
look it's the law which i follow to a t
it's just the rules
[Music]
easy huh all right well you're going in
have a good one the others do not agree
but i believe the man in red is not a
threat
what never mind okay
the man in red the dude the dude who is
trying to get a lot of uh
different stuff going on man there's so
much information that i'm trying to
juggle
all at once outer groose lusty cosmo
date is good male picture's kind of
bug-eyed but
it's whatever you're good so
that was a decent day why
follow the
god damn it son's birthday's in two days
small package arrived
ooh nice hey thanks for that
hey thank you well this is so far so
good everything seems to be running
smooth now import protests unbalanced
trade restrictions claims are
unfairly texas emporium goods our
associates iron border internal media
reveals entry visa bias
well look you didn't have an entry
permit you didn't have an entry permit
what am i gonna do about that you didn't
have a permit
if you don't have a permit what am i
going to do nothing unfavorable
international presses affected
immigration protocol denials must be
accompanied by a reason for denial stamp
a new computer ranking system has been
installed interrogate discrepancies to
prime
the reason for denial stamp if applicant
clarifies discrepancy sufficiently
approval is authorized even while reason
for denial stamp remains available
interesting more things i gotta do but
okay
all right let's do this i guess so many
goddamn rules
hey what's up how you doing where's your
supplementation
okay you never got one you got this and
then the reason
reason for denial there you go you got
you got it and then you're good
for what reason it's clearly stamped
there
oh screw you anyways well look
my dude my man it is what it is
jenna stora nice band to remember that
game intense good
good glad you liked it okay you're not
on my list
all looks good here go rsk rs kick
yeah you know man you know it man you
know it man
visiting duration two weeks
that is good name is good used to be an
inspector like you back
in the fed we denied most people it's
all done by computers now
they can deny much faster that way yeah
you're right it would be much faster if
a computer did this because i feel like
they could do that
instead of me however you are good
you are not getting denied today thank
you for having all of your stuff in
order
good luck work 60 days good
dates good whoa okay okay okay
okay okay got this all right here we go
and
gotcha
yeah easy the day was cut short by a
terrorist attack your son's birthday is
tomorrow
he wants an expensive crayon set how
expensive can a crayon set be
almost as much as rent what the frick
are these crayons kid
goddamn those crayons more than food we
can't eat those what are you even doing
kid
draw with a rock burn a piece of wood
and use it for charcoal drawing
learn to adapt with the tools that you
have child
crayons 25 crayons
goddamn that's a whole month of rent or
day i guess it's a whole day of rent
i shot a dude today i could have gotten
you some red
want to get a cake look i'll pull some
food together we'll get you a whole
nother
day's worth of food you can eat like a
pig stuff yourself full
puke you got green you got all the
colors of a rainbow inside your body you
just gotta extract it
okay whatever happy birthday son happy
birthday
real happy to have you in my life impor
begins trade sanctions immediately
restricts all imports from arstotzka
how does that affect me does that affect
me in any way
is that something i gotta deal with some
other new layer of [ __ ] import
rejects all important goods from
arstotzka under a request from the
ministry of trade the ministry a mission
will react to this violation
my aim is not like before you're lucky
i'm here else you would have done ben
blowed the frick up but i ain't gonna
let that happen
okay so all impor people get denied
well that whoa we got freaking jason
trying to cross the border here
let's get this done hey what's up you
from import oh sorry
oh man this really is a thing um
look you uh look you gotta you gotta go
sorry impor is no good no good
my god you guys are making this easy on
me you guys are making this
easy you guys are making this
easy on me look i'm fine with this
hey have a good day i know you are you
from
nurse i worked with your father years
ago oh cool i was a little brat
thanks guess what hey i'm in charge of
whether you get in
east creston there's gonna be something
wrong here
alton and whatever screw you
you're a brat just get gone go back to
nurse and tell them you're doing well
here
oh thank you that makes me feel better
makes me feel better oh my wanted
criminal there okay
number matches name matches bobbed hair
weight matches expiration is okay it is
good you're good to go
thankfully you're not from emporer
because we ain't importing anything from
there
oh hey wow here you are again yeah you
are everything's set up now
come through often to see me good
friends yeah
it's weird passport number from skal a
skull well you're lucky you're not from
impor
i mean it all seems to line up pretty
good here
mustache oh what's with the weight pal
my wife very bad cook
[Laughter]
maybe you not like this what am i not
like
what am i not like my dude
what what is that what is this my dude
what is this what is this
oh
okay you're not a threat you know what
just go man just go i like you just go
okay thanks buddy thank you
sure oh nope sorry buddy
no entry from him poor i know it seems
in
poor taste but whatever it is good name
still matches
working the this is not oh yes it is i
see
tiny moi there okay great rapid
united federation great rapid it's good
birthday's good
you're good to go we got no we got very
few troublemakers today
some nice friendly people why invalid
work end date what do you mean
work end date i didn't even know there
was a work end date there's a work end
date what do you mean a work end date
what does that even mean
probably less ranadi yeah
okay just go
i probably missed something there too
i'm losing my touch
yep i did
hey what's this all about we have some
questions for you
you do not like my tone while i don't
like your face i'm shocked that that
actually was even remotely kind of like
you but whatever
it's fine it's all good it's all good
whatever
it's all fine it's fine your son has
drawn a picture for you to take to work
thanks kid thanks kid that's great kid
that's great that's really good stuff
import sanctions end over so fast what
happened
well i don't know maybe they were unfair
i have no idea okay so that's all i have
for this episode it's getting a little
aggravating because there's so much
stuff that i have to juggle but i assume
that it's all gonna come falling apart
as soon as everything blows up around me
but i'm alive and so is my family and my
son drew me a picture so that
that really is all that really matters
at the end of the day so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]
bye